[موسيقى]
في جنون بيجتاح مساحه من شبكه الانترنت في
عدد من دول العالم بقى له سنتين تحديدا لا
اسباب بالنسبه لمعظم الناس غير مفهومه
تعالوا نبص على السبع صور اللي قدامكم دول
فكرتهم بسيطه خالص واحد صحي من النوم
الصبح وقرر يرسم صوره وحولها لانفتي
واعرضها للبيع على مواقع بيع الانفتيس
والسبع صور دول هم اعلى صور اتباعت كائن
فتيس خلال الاسبوع اللي فات ده من وقت
تصوير الحلقه مثلا اول صوره على اليمين
بتاعه القرد اللي رقبته نص اليه ده اتباعت
خلال الاسبوع اللي انا بصور فيه الحلقه دي
ب 149 الف دولار صوره البنت اتباعت ب 354
الف دولار والصوره اللي بعدها
ب400 الف دولار دي مجرد عينه من الاف
الصور اللي بتتبعي يوميا على مواقع بيع
وهي ما فيهاش اختراع ولا اسرار كونيه مجرد
صوره بسيطه تصميم لحد او رسمه ديجيتال
عاديه او رسومات وشخبطه لاطفال صغيرين
فايه الجنان اللي بيحصل ده ممكن يوصل لفين
قبل ما اجاوب خليني احكي لكم قصه هتصدمكم
ده
رسام رقمي ومصمم جرافيك امريكي معروف
باسمه الاشهر في 2007 مايك كان شاب بسيط
عنده 26 سنه في اول السنه فكروا انه يبدا
روتين توثيق يومي بالتصميم لمده 5000 يوم
يوم الصبح من النوم يقعد يعمل تصميم اي
تصميم رقمي من وحي خياله وينشره للناس
ويخزنوا عنده وينساه ويبدا اليوم اللي
بعده وهكذا مايك بدا فكرته دي في واحد
مايو 2007 وحافظ على روتينو ده وصمم 5000
تصميم في 5000 يوم فعلا يعني تقريبا 14
سنه وكل يوم كانت مهاراته بتتطور واعجاب
الناس بتصميماته بيزيد واسمه بيتشاير اكتر
يوم 21 فبراير 2021 مايك كان مخلص التحدي
بتاعه وجمع كل تصميماته
في 2017 ودلوقتي المنصه عليها حجم تداول
يومي ب 70 مليار دولار فايه بقى وازاي
بتتباع بالمبالغ المذهله دي وايه اشكالها
وهل دي فن حقيقي ولا فقاعه وحتنفجر في وش
العالم من غير ما يحس والناس اللي بيشتروا
دول مجانين ولا طبيعيين زينا يعني ليه
بيدفعوا الفلوس دي كلها في شويه صور ممكن
انا وانت وجميع سكان الكره الارضيه ننزلها
عادي على تليفوناتنا واجهزتنا ونتفرج
عليها ونبعتها لبعض على واتساب والسؤال
الاهم بقى ازاي تطور استخدام الانفتي وبقى
داخل في سلاسل توريد دلوقتي دي عينه من
الاسئله المهمه جدا لقصه حلقتنا النهارده
واللي هنحاول نجاوب عليها مع بعض بس قبل
ما نبدا بفكركم بالاشتراك في القناه
اشتراككم مهم جدا وبيطور من شغلنا وبفكركم
ان كل حلقاتنا اللي فاتت مترجمه
للانجليزيه فما تنسوش تشاركوها مع اصحابكم
الاجانب وتعرفوهم علينا باكد بس في
البدايه ان عمليات بيع وشراء الانفتيز
متاحه بس في الدول المصرح فيها بتداول
العملات المشفره والانفتيه واللي الحلقه
دي موجهه لهم انا اشرف ابراهيم وده المقبل
الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
حابب اشكر منصه باينانس اكبر بورصه لتداول
العملات المشفره في العالم على رعايه
الحلقه دي علشان ادخلكم عالم الانفتيز
بشكل سهل هدردش معكم شويه عن حاجه عزيزه
عليا عدد كبير من حضراتكم بيسالني عليها
دي الساعه بتاعتي اللي متابع المقبل
الاقتصادي من فتره فهو عينه متعوده عليها
لان بلبسها في كل الحلقات من فتره طويله
وهي عزيز عليا جدا لان اشتريتها مع صديق
في موقف معين ومن ساعتها صورت بها اكتر من
350 حلقه وبمرور الوقت بقت جزء مني ومن
هويه البرنامج وبحب البسها هي بالذات في
الحلقات رغم ان انا عندي ساعات احدث منها
ولكن الساعه دي لها خصوصيه عندي لو انت
عاوز تشتري ساعه زيها او شبهها يا اما
هتروح محل ساعات او هتدور على الانترنت
وتشتريها وهتلاقي في الاف الساعات اللي
زيها او قريبه منها في التصميم واللون
وباسعار متفاوته فالطبيعي انك هتشتري اقرب
واحده ليها لكن هل ده معناه ان الساعه
بتاعتي قابله للاستبدال يعني ممكن ابدلها
باي ساعه تانيه مع واحد صاحبي مثلا في
الحقيقه لا ساعتي غير قابله للاستبدال ليه
بقى لان دي مش مجرد ساعه وخلاص وانما لها
قيمه معنويه وعاطفيه عندي وبالتالي فهي
نادره جدا بالنسبه لي فكلنا تقريبا عندنا
حاجات زي دي بالظبط مرتبطه بذكريات او
احداث معينه ولو حد عرض عليكم اضعاف تمنها
فغالبا مش هتوافقوا تفرطوا فيها علشان كده
الحاجات دي بنوصفها بغير قابله للاستبدال
وفي الاقتصاد كل الحاجات بتنقسم لقسمين
اما اشياء قابله للاستبدال بسهوله او غير
قابله للاستبدال لندرتها يعني الحاجات
اليوميه اللي بناكلها او بنشربها او فئات
العملات مثلا معظمها قابل للاستبدال بيطلع
من المنتج الواحد اعداد مهوله من مصانع
بتاعته يوميه لكن لو بصينا لشيء زي لوحه
الموناليزا اللي قدامنا دي هل نقدر نبدلها
عادي باي لوحه موناليزا تانيه رسمها اي حد
اكيد لا اللوحه الاصليه هي لوحه واحده بس
في العالم وبالتالي فهي غير قابله
للاستبدال اوبل من هنا جت تسميه الانفتيس
[موسيقى]
او الرموز غير القابله للاستبداد وهي
عباره عن اصول رقميه بيتم تخزينها على
سلسله الكتل بلوكت شاه يعني ايه برضو يعني
اي حاجه نقدر نحولها بس لازم تكون نادره
علشان تتباع او يكون لها قيمه عند حد تاني
فيدفع فيها فلوس يعني تكون فريده من نوعها
وما فيش منها اثنين او غير قابله
للاستبدال لقيمتها الفنيه او المعنويه او
الاثنين مع بعض زي الساعه بتاعتي دي اللي
لها قيمه معنويه عندي وقيمه جماهريه عندكم
فممكن احولها هنا بقى او الرموز غير
القابله للاستبدال تعتبر زي شهادات ملكيه
للاصول سواء كانت الاصول دي افتراضيه زي
الصور اللي بدانا بها الحلقه او ماديه زي
الساعه بتاعتي دي فانا لما اجي ابيعها
معناه اني ببيع الملكيه دي لحد تاني طب
ازاي هحول الحاجه معي سواء كانت اصل رقمي
او افتراضي او اصل مادي ولتكن الساعه
بتاعتي دي الحقيقه ان الخطوات بسيطه جدا
الخطوه رقم واحد لو شيء مادي زي الساعه
هقوم مصورها اما فيديو 3d او هاخد لها
مجموعه صور لكن لو مثلا هعمل لصوره معي
على التليفون او صوره انا رسمتها على
برنامج او تصميم رقمي فمش محتاجه اصورها
بطبيعه الحال الخطوه رقم اتنين بحول الصور
اللي انا اخدتها مثلا للساعه بتاعتي لا
نفتيل ازاي بقى عن طريق اني بدخل على منصه
متخصصه في الانفتيز زي منصه
وبرفع مجموعه او كولكشن صور بتاعه الساعه
وبكتب وصف دقيق للساعه نفسها وخصائص
اجزائها ومكمل الندره بتاعتها بعد كده
المنصه نفسها بترفعها على البلوكتشين او
سلسله
باختصار شديد هو السجل للاحتفاظ بالبيانات
والمعلومات اللي منها بيانات تي او الرمز
غير القابل للاستبدال وبكده بقيت انت الوح
في العالم اللي مالك للانفتي ده والعالم
كله يقدر يدخل ويتاكد من ملكيتك ليه
مستحيل حد يسرقه او يخترقه وهو مش معاه
المفاتيح علشان تعرفوا بالتفصيل ايه هي
سلسله الكتل او البلوكتشين والمفاتيح
وغيرها ضروري تتفرجوا على حلقات سلسله
الكريبتو اللي وضحت فيها بشكل بسيط جدا
عالم العملات المشفره
ارادنا ثمان حلقات مكملين بعض وهنكمل
السلسله قريب باذن الله هتلاقوا حلقات
السلسله هنا بعد ما تعمل اللي فات ده كله
مبروك بقى معك اما تستخدمها استخدام شخصي
زي مثلا تغير صوره البروفايل زي تويتر
مثلا واما تقرر تباعها وساعتها ممكن تحتفظ
بها بشكل مؤقت مثلا هتقول للناس انك عندك
رمز غير قابل للاستبدال او ان اف تي بس مش
هتبيعه دلوقتي علشان عدد كبير من الناس
يعرف وجود الاول وبعدين تبيعه علشان تاخد
فيه اعلى سعر يعني مثلا فاكرين الصوره دي
اتوجلاف اللي اتكلمنا عليها في المقدمه
الراجل اللي عمل لها منتج يعني حولها
انفتي من اربع سنين
مسقعه فتره واخر سعر اتباعت به كربعمائه
الف دولار زي ما وضحنا فده كده خيار في
خيار تاني بعد ما تعمل انك تبيع رمز على
طول وساعتها هترفعه على موقع من مواقع بيع
كمازاد وتحدد السعر المبدئي او الاسك او
الفيست برايس وطبعا البيع والشراء بيتم من
خلال العملات المشفره زي الايسر مثلا
وممكن كمان اضيف لها شرط
اللي هو عباره عن ان اخد نسبه مئويه معينه
من تمن البيع في كل مره تتباع فيها بعد
كده في منصات كتير مشهوره لبيع وشراء زي
منصه طبعا البيانات اللي قدامنا دي بتتغير
مستبته فدي البيانات وقت تصوير الحلقه
مثلا العمود اللي على الشمال تحت
هتلاقي اسماء الشركات المنتجه للانفتيز او
الملاك بتوع يعني لو رفعت الان اف تي
بتاعت سعد دي وربنا كرمنا وكان عليها كميه
تداول كبيره فهنلاقي المخبر الاقتصادي على
الشمال كده مع الشركات دي العمود التاني
في كميه المبيعات اللي تمت في ال 24 ساعه
للكوليكشن او المجموعه دي من الانفتيس زي
ما احنا شايفين اول مجموعه اتباع منها بما
يعادل 6000 ايثر او 9.7 مليون دولار في 24
ساعه العمود اللي بعد كده بيقيس نسبه
التغير في المبيعات العمود اللي بعد كده
هو اقل سعر موجوده في الكولكشن او
المجموعه دي وهو هنا حوالي 24 الف دولار
العمود اللي بعده بيعبر عن نسبه التغير في
سعر اقل العمود اللي بعد كده اللي هو
الاونرز او عدد الملاك اللي موجودين في
المجموعه دي وهم هنا اثنين بس اخر عمود هو
عدد الانفتيس في المجموعه دي وهنا 10,000
انفتيس طيب انا عملت ساعه انفتي قبل تصوير
الحلقه مباشره ورفعتها على منصه زي ما
انتم شايفين تجربه عمليه قدامكم هنا في
سؤال بيفرض نفسه هل هبيع ساعه كان في تي
يعني صوره بس ولا هبيعها ومع ساعه نفسها
كاصل مادي ده بيكون على حسب اختياري ممكن
ابيعها كان في تي بس وممكن ابيعها كان في
تي ومعاه الساعه نفسها طيب انا كاشرف هعمل
ايه في الساعه دي انا هبيعها كاني في تي
ومعاه الساعه نفسها لسبب مهم جدا وخيري
هتعرفوه في نهايه الحلقه علشان كده ضروري
تكملوا معايا للاخر هنا حد ممكن يسالني
سؤال حلو قوي وبديه ليه يا اشرف في شخص
بالغ عاقل ممكن يدفع في اي صوره فلوس
علشان يبقى مالك اصل للصوره دي في حين انه
يقدر يشوفها على الانترنت عادي او ياخد
لها سكرين شوت ويستخدمها بشكل مجاني تماما
مبدئيا كده اي حاجه لها قيمه بين الناس في
الحياه عموما فهي قيمتها مستمده من فكره
ان الناس اتفقت او قررت انها لها قيمه
بمنتهى البساطه يعني مثلا بصوا على صوره
القرد زهقان ده بورد ايف تمانيه تمانيه
واحد سبعه باي منطقه الصوره اللي قدام
حضراتكم دي تتباع كاني في تي في اكتوبر
الخاصه بالصور والموسيقى والمواد
الابداعيه ثانيه واحده ايه ده هو في
موسيقى او حاجات تانيه غير الصور
والرسومات بتتعمل الاجابه ايوه ممكن تكون
مثلا قطعه موسيقيه عادي جدا زي بعض قطع
المطربه الكنديه اللي اتبعت في مارس 2021
كان فتيز مقابل 6 مليون دولار وممكن تبقى
بوست على فيسبوك او تغريد على تويتر مثلا
زي التغريده الاولى على تويتر لاحد مؤسسه
الموقع جاك دورسي اللي اتبعت باثنين فاصل
تسعه مليون دولار مع ملاحظه ان ده برضو
كان في مارس 2021 هو الوقت اللي كانت فيه
ظاهره الانفتيز منتشره ولها زخم واسع جدا
طبعا في 2022 سواء تراجع بشده وفقد الزخم
ده علشان كده مثلا نلاقي الانفتي بتاع
التويتر دلوقتي سعره خسف بالارض وما فيش
حد عاوز يشتريه وممكن الانف تي يكون مقطع
فيديو على اليوتيوب زي مقطع شهير عنوانه
شارلي هو اللي قدامنا ده اتعرض سنه 2007
على اليوتيوب وهو لسه موقع ناشئ وفي طفلين
واحد فيهم بيعض صباع اخوه بس كده ده كل
الاكشن وفي مايو 2021
المقطع اتبعت حقوقه وانتقلت ملكيته كان من
على اليوتيوب ب 761 الف دولار تقريبا
وممكن الانفتيس تكون اغراض في لعبه زي
لعبه اكس انفينيتي كل الملابس اللي في
اللعبه وتغيير اشكال الشخصيات وغيرها
بيتباع وكان افتيس وممكن يكون الغرض من
بيع الانفتيز هو جمع الاموال للاعمال
الخيريه وده اللي هنعمله في نهايه الحلقه
بالمناسبه مش عايز اطول عليكم اكتر من كده
بس قبل ما انهي الحلقه لازم نقف شويه هنا
على ملاحظه همهد بها للجزء التاني من
الموضوع ده الجنون اللي فات ده كله حاجه
واللي بالمناسبه في ناس شايفاه فقاعه
وحتنفجر في اي لحظه والفائده الحقيقيه من
وجهه نظري للانفتي حاجه ثانيه خالص يعني
انا بالنسبه لي الفايده في اجابات اسئله
زي مثلا ازاي التقنيه دي طورت وبقت تدخل
في سلاسل التوريد وفي الصناعات دلوقتي هنا
في ثوره بدات تحصل وبتزيد اهميتها بمرور
الوقت ازاي بيتم استخدامها في تتبع مصدر
الاغذيه او الادويه او الملابس مثلا وازاي
بتستخدم في مجال العقارات ازاي الانفتيز
بتقضي على الشركات الاحتياليه اللي بتغرق
الاسواق بمكوناته اجزاء ومنتجات مقلده
وبالتالي بتحمي الشركات الكويسه وبتمنع
عنها خسائر ضخمه بسبب تقليد منتجاتها ازاي
بتمنع عملت الاطفال وبتحسن من ظروف العمل
في الدول الفقيره زي بعض الدول الافريقيه
مثلا وازاي بتساهم في دفعه سياحه
والاقتصاد في دوله زي اليابان مثلا ده
الاهم عندي طبعا وده موضوع عايز حلقه
لوحده لانه مهم جدا جدا ولو وضحته هنا
بسرعه في نهايه الحلقه فانا كده بظلمه
تماما فانا هعمل حلقه تانيه ان شاء الله
عن ثوره الانفتيز في سلاسل التوريد
النهارده عرفونا رايكم في التعليقات لو
حابين تشوفوها وما تنسوش تشتركوا في
القناه علشان تتابعوا الحلقه اول ما
نعملها وننزلها ان شاء الله نيجي بقى
للمذات الخيري اللي عاوزين نعمله مع بعض
زي ما قلت لكم بتيجي لي اسئله كتير جدا عن
السعه بتاعتي زي ما شرحت اول الحلقه
كمتخليها انها غاليه او ماركه مثلا لكن هي
ساعه لها عند ذكرى جميله مقيمه خاصه فانا
قررت اعمل لها على منصه باينانس انفتي
وافتح مزاد عليه وهبيع باعلى سعر لاعلى
مزايد ومعاه الساعه نفسها المزاد ده
هنفتحه قريب جدا ان شاء الله لحد ما اكبر
عدد من الناس يعرفوا بالموضوع والجهه اللي
هيتم التبرع لها بقيمه الساعه نفسها هي
مؤسسه مرسال مؤسسه مرسال اللي ما يعرفش من
حضراتكم هي اول مؤسسه خيريه في مصر تتخصص
في علاج المرضى الفقراء جدا وغير القادرين
من مختلف الاعمار والجنسيات يعني مش
المرضى المصريين بس وعندهم فريق ممتاز
وبحث حاله دقيق ونظام اداري جيد جدا لضمان
وصول العلاج لمستحقيه وتوسيع التبرعات
باقصى قدر من العداله هنحط لكم روابط
صفحات المؤسسه على المنصات المختلفه في
صندوق الوصف تقدروا تزوروها وتتاكدوا
بنفسكم فان شاء الله قيمه المزاد بالكامل
هتروح للمؤسسه وهناكد ده بعد ما يتم بطرق
توثيق مختلفه في النهايه يا ريت لو عجبكم
الفيديو تعملوا لايك وشير واهم حاجه تحكم
لاصحابكم وحبايبكم عننا يمكن يستفيدوا ما
تنسوش تشتركوا في القناه علشان تشوفوا كل
حلقاتنا سلام
[موسيقى]